the pekiri river
the forests and the wetlands it runs
through are shrouded
in a thick dense fog of smoke
vets and trackers taking to boats in a
desperate animal rescue
the fires have been burning here for
months the inhabitants of the pantanal
the world's largest tropical wetlands
are all in dangerously poor shape
but the rescue team is searching for
jaguars
burnt out of their natural habitat
they've made it to the river
looking for food and looking for safety
the largest population of jaguars in the
world is here
some of the survivors of the fires are
injured
she's limping but mobile eyeing up
a family of otters but too slow
they escape heads popping out of the
water calling out a warning
that a predator is near
the jackets are coming down to the water
to hand
you can see
she or he is not well at all hobbling
slightly
i think she was after some otters that
have left
but more and more of the uh the jaguars
are
finding life really difficult um in the
whole of the landscape that's now been
burned and
say the easiest way to hunt is to come
down by the water
but the hunting capability is obviously
impaired
the vet team are specialists with big
cats
they're monitoring survivors reports
from fishermen have been coming in
that at least one of the jaguars that is
injured
has been spotted we catch them up
they assess the injuries he's four or
five years old
the fires have forced jaguars to share
the same territory
it is often a violent mix but simply
they fight
because of the fire the jaguars have
changed the territory
and then they can find other jaggers and
just put the territory
so we think that probably this guy will
have this project
the good news is that the jaguar has
been hunting
and will
be able to stay here obviously under
anaesthetic at the moment
one of the plans was to take him away
and to treat him but he's okay
because he's hunting they patch him up
and eject antibiotics before moving him
away from the river
slowly but surely he recovers
so far though the pantanal is not
recovering
there are always dry season fires in the
pantanal but nothing like this
the bodies of animals are strewn across
the wetland swamp
now ravaged by fire
caymans an indigenous alligator lie
where they died
trying to escape the flames
nearby ponds are nearly dry
the caymans have congregated here in
huge numbers
hundreds of them dinosaur descendants
facing another apocalyptic moment in
their own
more modern history
neither land nor air animals are safe
from the fires
vets treat an injured hawk brought to an
animal aid station at the entrance to
the reservation
[Music]
she's lost her mother and is starving
and scared
quite the most cute thing you will ever
see safe now
but her life has changed forever
the pantanal will survive this drought
but this generation of animals will not
be the same
and there are only so many droughts they
can survive
mr ramsey sky news brazil